This differential equation would mean that T1 decays exponentially to zero.
We're losing a certain fraction every hour. This does not make sense.
With this differential equation, T2 would gain from T1.
The red process would be in place, but we would never lose anything--this is not true.
In the second differential equation, initially T2 is smaller than T1,
meaning that this difference is negative.
The rate of change of T2 would initially at least be negative which doesn't make sense T2 has to grow.
The first one is correct. The percentage of 10%--0.1 per hour of T2 flowing into T1
and there is minus 10% per hour of T1 flowing out of T1
and in a similar fashion the lower one is true as 10% per hour of T1 flowing into T2 a plus sign
here and there is minus 10% per hour of T2 flowing out of T2 minus.
So actually what's of interest to us is only the difference of the temperatures. Footnote.
So we could have been using degrees Celsius and degrees Fahrenheit all the way
because we're forming this difference and are not interested in the total amount
of energy contained in each compartment.